[موسيقى]
كثير من رموز السياسيه والفكريه التي كانت
تقود الاحزاب وتقود المعارضه وبعضهم كان
حتى في السلطه من قاده الحركه الاسلاميه
كانوا يمثلون مستودع للحكمه ولكن مع
التغيير غالب هذا الشخصيات غابت بالموتى
الطبيعي اغلبهم وبعضهم بالتقدم العمر
فتصدت للقياده بعد الثوره اجيال شابه
عندها تجارب محدوده ولذلك انا دعوت اول ما
دعوت انه الثورات كلها تحتاج الى قيمه
اسمها التسامح السودان يحتاج الى مصالحه
ضخمه مصالحه كتل ليس فقط بين الدعم السريع
والجيش ولكن اقاليم باكملها في السودان
غرقت في الحرب
الاهليهم اهملت منذ منذ البدايه
الان هنالك جدل عن ادماج
حركات الجيوش الدعم السريع في الجيش وهذه
تجربه في العالم كله موجوده يعني وفيها
حلول وافكار ورؤى وتفاصيل فنيه يمكن ان
نصل الى حلب ولكن
المعضله هي انه كيف يمكن ان نجد صيقه نحدد
بها كيف يحكم السودان
ولكن واضح ان المؤسس العسكريه في السودان
لها خبره سياسيه ضخمه وراكم التجارب وهم
يدرسون التكتيك والمناوره ولذلك يفيدون
التدخل في العمل السياسي طيله عهد الانقاذ
كانت كل مره اتصل فيها المفاوضات السلام
مع الحركه الشعبيه الى مرحله تسبب التوقيع
ينهار لانه الجيش يتحرك ويحتل مدينه فهو
غارق في السياسه متعمق فيها يجيد اللعب
فيها باكثر مما يجيد المدنيون فلذلك لن
يخرج بهذه السهوله هي صيقه المصالحه التي
كان يسميها الاستاذ منصور خالد العوده الى
منصه التاسيس تشمل حتى نظريه امن قومي
للبلاد واذا كانت نظريه امن قومي سيكون
هنالك عقيده عسكريه متفق عليها هناك ينبغي
ان يقوم مؤتمر للنظام الحكم يحدد ان
السودان يحكم فيدراليا الفيدرالي لها
شرطين لابد منهما هما الجيش الواحد
والديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]